caesar this is your third movie with the
coen brothers i think they have to be my
favorite uh filmmakers and when i hear
the coen brothers have a movie that
you're in it it's got this incredible
cast and that it takes place in the 40s
i'm the first guy that wants to see that
movie i absolutely loved it it was
absolutely fantastic it was great
what is your relationship like first of
all they put you in in some cool movies
what is your relationship with the
cohen's like where they like to use you
again and again
so boring
they're they're they're literally they
have nothing to say they're the great
they're they're like the original
they're ah how do i put it
there's nothing interesting to talk
about when you talk about the cohens
because there's nothing happening
um it all i don't know what to say
this means uh they're nice people
they're really nice people and like
great artists like if you think of
pollock if you think of that you don't
want to bring pollock to your dinner
party you know what i mean you just want
him to do the drip art and then you want
him to create and you want to see it but
you don't necessarily want to hang out
with them
what a nice thing to say about the
fellow brothers
no so apparently hail caesar is your
final this is my last film
it's my trilogy no no they're very
they're very sweet they're very sweet
they're very laconic but they're very
sweet i usually do this thing with them
where we're sitting nobody's saying
anything we're looking down waiting for
a scene to be done and i do what you
don't do to any successful director as
an actor is you go
guys you know what i have to break the
silence for it you know but i'm sorry
but um i have a script that i think
would be great for you
and usually ethan goes oh jesus
and then i go into a 10-minute breakdown
of this great town next to fargo
the movie that i want to be in that also
by the way has a submarine in it
and then i go understand they don't
think it's funny there's nobody who ever
laughs i think it's freaking hilarious
because he's got yeah you're completely
wasting their time which i really
appreciate i'm sorry which is a
performance art of sorts you but you
know what as long as they keep hiring a
man it's all good because i love doing
movies with them i think they're the
greatest directors out there yeah they
this film you know what i love it was a
weird experience too
uh
the movie takes place on a hollywood lot
it's not supposed to be the warner
brothers lot but they use the warner
brothers lot and you play a fixer a guy
who works at the studio making sure
everything runs smoothly there's so many
i watched it here in a screening room on
the lot
walked out
into the world that you're spending the
whole movie in it's absolutely
fascinating yeah when i when i drove in
here and i saw that thing and it
reminded me you know i mean that's the
thing is it's a whole like throwback and
degree but this is better i heard now i
don't know if this is true or not and
really up to you guys whether this
becomes true or not this is supposed to
be bigger than star wars
[Laughter]
seriously that's the buzz i've heard
yeah yeah the budget
is like between 500 600 million and if
we end up making
three billion dollars
we have
[Applause]